هل توجد حياه اخرى خارج الارض
سؤال يتكرر كل ما ظهرت جثث كائنات غريبه
ناس عدت ذلك لغزا مثيرا للجدل ولم تدلي
برايا قاطع وعلماء الفلك دهشوا من تجاهل
الادله والزراء العلم
اجسام غريبه وتساؤلات محيره عام
1961 تداولت الصحف العالميه قصه اغرب من
الخيال عن زوجين امريكيين تمكنا من الفرار
بصعوبه من جسم غامض مضيء مرعب يسير على
قدمين ينظر اليهما من النافذه ولا يبدو
انه من البشر الجسم الغريب كان يحوم
فوقهما في اثناء قياده سيارتهما في طريق
مهجور في الجبال البيضاء بولايه نيوهام
شمال شرق الولايات المتحده الزوجان بيتي
وبارني هيل عاد الى المنزل بعد محاوله
هروب منهكه ووجدا صعوبه كبيره في تذكر ما
حدث معهما خاصه بعد العثور على فستان
الزوجه ممزقا وحذاء الزوج مهترئه
وساعتيهما متوقفتين في التوقيت نفسه
[موسيقى]
تعرف
الحادثه سجلت اول محاوله اختطاف موثقه
ينفذها جسم غامض بعد خضوع الزوجين للتنويم
المغناطيسي تحدثا خلاله بالتفاصيل عما حدث
معهما
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الامريكي السابق اوباما اقر خلال
لقاء تلفزيوني بان الكائنات الفضائيه
موجوده فعلا ولا يمكن انكارها خاصه بعد
رؤيته لقطات مسجله وموثقه عند توليه منصب
الرئاسه تثبت وجود كائن فضائي مجهول عام
1961 في العام نفسه الذي حدثت فيه محاوله
اختطاف الزوجين
نو
عام 2020 قرر البنتاجون ازاحه الستار ورفع
السريه عن الظواهر الجويه المجهوله ونشر
مقاطع فيديو وصورا حقيقيه التقطت ما بين
عامي 2007
و20017 توضح وجود اجسام مستديره مجهوله
الهويه في السماء كانت تحلق بسرعه
رهيبه داخل الغلاف الجوي للارض مع سماع
تسجيلات صوتيه لافراد من القوات البحريه
الامريكيه انذاك وهم يعبرون عن الصدمه
والرعب من هول ما حدث بعض العلماء رجحوا
ان تكون هذه اللقطات قرائنه تدل على ان
البشر لا يعيشون وحدهم في هذا الكوكب في
حين شكك اخرون في ان تكون تلك اللقطات
لكائنات او مخلوقات فضائيه ورجحوا ان يكون
مصدر تلك الومضات ضوئيه طبيعي
عام 2023 استيقظ العالم على مفاجاه احدث
الضجه واسعه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
بعد ان عرض الصحفي خايمي موسان وبتغريبه
امام الكونجرس المكسيكي تحوي على جثتين
محنطتين لكائنات مجهوله لها ثلاثه اصابع
ومشوهه الراس وزعم انها تعود الى مخلوقات
فضائيه يبلغ عمرها الف سنه واستند خايمي
الى تحليلات بالكربون 14 اجرتها جامعه
مكسيكيه مستقله ولكن ثابت ان هاتين
الجثتين لا علاقه لهما بالكائنات الفضائيه
فقبل عده سنوات فحصهما عالم انثروبولوجيا
اكد انهما من بقايا بشريه محنطه مختلفه
الولايات المتحده طالبت نموذجا من هذه
الجثث للمزيد من التحقيق اما ناسا فقالت
انها لم تتوصل حتى الان الى تفسير لهذه
الظاهره الغريبه على سطح الارض
وانتم هل تؤمنون بوجود الكائنات الفضائيه